emmanuel macron appel au plus grand
calme au moment où des convois de
véhicules se dirige vers paris pour
protester contre l'impasse vaccinale et
gouvernement le chef de l'état dans une
interview au quotidien ouest france
déclare entendre et respecter la fatigue
et la colère liée à la crise sanitaire
sur le terrain message de fermeté
blindés et barricades anti émeute les
forces de l'ordre sont mobilisés pour
éviter tout blocage de la capitale où la
préfecture a interdit le rassemblement
de ces convois interdiction maintenu par
la justice depuis hier partie de toute
la france quelques trois mille trois
cents véhicules selon la police
convergent vers paris en voiture en
camion en moto ou en camping car notre
reporter katia technique suit lé convoi
qui doit partir d'orléans elle est en
direct à la griffe
bonsoir katyal convoi doit rejoindre
paris pour l'instant il est toujours
bloquée
oui alors ici on peut pas parler
vraiment de blocage parce que les
centaines et centaines de voitures qui
ont afflué pendant deux heures la
vraiment juste il ya deux minutes il y
avait encore des klaxons des et des
minibus des vannes des voitures qui
passait juste à côté de moi en fait ils
signent un point d'étape 1 avec
différents convois qui ont convergé
peut-être que les personnes vont dresser
un petit moment parce qu'il y avait un
grand comité d'accueil pour pour les
réceptionner avec de la nourriture avec
des boissons il ya même eu un feu
d'artifice qui a été attirée donc en
tout cas les personnes qui sont ici
vont-elles remonter à paris tout de
suite on ne sait pas en tout cas c'était
très impressionnant parce que le cortège
a grandit au fur et à mesure au départ
il n'y avait que peut-être une petite
centaine de soutien et maintenant il ya
vraiment plusieurs centaines de
personnes avec des drapeaux avec des
gilets jaunes beaucoup de présence de
gilet jaune également et puis tous
scandent liberté liberté et alors
évidemment beaucoup d'émotion aussi chez
ceux qui ont parcouru des centaines de
kilomètres pour se retrouver ici à
orléans je vous propose de les écouter
le pouvoir d'achat chacun le fait avec
ses moyens moi je suis pour le pouvoir
de vivre c'est à dire que home vie avec
ses moyens mais j'ai pas envie de
présenter un qr code pour boire un café
assis ou debout en fonction du bon
vouloir de notre long dirigeants nous on
vient de cnds s'inquiète au dessus de
toulouse et je crois que moi je fais
partie du mouvement des gilet jaune
depuis trois ans et je crois que là
vraiment on n'a jamais eu un soutien
comme ça de du peuple français alors
leurs revendications sans surprise
évidemment c'est une opposition aux
restrictions sanitaires quand en prison
depuis plusieurs mois le pass vaccinale
le pass sanitaire qui entravent leur
mouvement qui
style entrave à leur liberté
il ya également ici des soignants qui
n'ont pas accepté de se faire vacciner
donc qui ont été suspendus et qui ne
touchent pas de salaire qui n'ont pas de
ressources aujourd'hui d'où les mots qui
reviennent dans leur bouche et sur les
voitures qui sont placardés liberté
liberté et puis il ya bien sûr des
revendications sociales ici les gens
répètent nous travaillons mais nous
n'arrivons pas à boucler nos fins de
mois à cause des prix qui augmentent
l'énergie l'inflation et elles sont en
grande difficulté aujourd'hui financière
alors malgré tout une très forte
solidarité une extrême bonne humeur ici
beaucoup d'émotion et de convivialité
puisque évidemment certaines ne peuvent
plus se réunir dans des lieux publics
donc ça change et évidemment cela
contraste avec l'humeur apparaît un
petit que emmanuel macron appeler au
plus grand des calmes et des barricades
ont été dressées je vous propose
d'écouter les réactions des manuels
macro et du préfet l'allemand
nous serons fermes mais nous empêcherons
les blocages la détermination des forces
de sécurité intérieure et entière le
niveau de mobilisation est significatif
et nous avons par rapport à ce qui a pu
se passer précédemment je pense
notamment au confinement les dispositifs
motorisés en nombre particulièrement
important les panneaux prochain divers
et véhicules blindés ils seront en
capacité de mettre fin à tout blocage
dans le cas extrême nous sommes tous
collectivement fatigué parce que nous
vivons depuis deux ans cette fatigue
s'exprime de plusieurs manières par du
désarroi chaise de la dépression chez
d'autres on voit une souffrance mentale
très forte chez nos jeunes et moins
jeunes et parfois cette fatigue se
traduit aussi par de la colère je
l'entends et la respecte mais j'en
appelle au plus grand calme
alors ici certains vont festoyer vont se
reposer après des centaines de
kilomètres on en voit certains qui
reprennent déjà la route en tout cas
distille ici c'est déjà une victoire que
cet immense mobilisation à travers toute
la france on parle de 3800 voiture un du
côté des organisateurs qui sont pas les
mêmes chiffres que ceux qui sont donnés
par la police une centaine de motos
également un élan très fort donc merci
beaucoup kata technique depuis orléans
vous retrouver tout à l'heure katia